[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit ce soir le coût réel du jeu en
ligne la pandémie a incité quand même
pas mal de gens à doubler la mise mais
ça se poursuit en rires et en fait on a
des chiffres tout frais sur cette
tendance là avec les paris sportifs liés
à la saison la nouvelle saison de la
ligue la ligue américaine de football
nfl la ligue les matchs des derniers
jours est une entreprise canadienne même
qui compile les données sur les mises et
on a enregistré depuis jeudi dernier 58
millions 200 mille paris sportifs en
lien avec la nfl sont en hausse de 126 %
comparativement à la même période l'an
dernier et c'est pas juste les paris
sportifs le sait tous les jeux d'argent
et de hasard en ligne qui connaissent
c'est peut-être tendance là on a des
chiffres de la canadian gaming associé
chez qui montre qu'en 2020 c'était des
paris en ligne le 2 peu près 1 825
dollars en moyenne par personne pour
ceux qui ont joué un total entre 15 et
30 milliards de dollars si tu t'y vas
voir un chiffre exact parce que je vous
rappelle que les casinos privée en ligne
c'est toujours illégal s'il y en a qui
trouvent quand même une façon de jouer
quand même mais là vous voyez les
chiffres pour une plateforme légale
espace jeux de loto québec la
fréquentation en hausse de 132% l'ariane
clairement une tendance et oui ça a
attiré beaucoup plus de gens pendant la
pandémie on estime que c'est à peu près
8 % des québécois dans ce cas c'est
qu'ils ont joué pour une première fois à
des jeux de hasard et de harnais
d'argent en ligne c'est presque un
québécois sur 10 20% d avoir joué au
moins une fois et de tous ceux qui
jouent en ligne 13 % gérard d'y jouer au
moins une fois par jour une fois par
jour quand même il ya des gens qui
perdent beaucoup d'argent mais c'est la
santé également tu peux être affecté
c'est les deux c'est des chiffres on a
des chiffres de l'institut national de
la santé publique du québec qui montrent
que de tous ces joueurs 26 % disent
avoir trop dépenser avec les jeux en
ligne 25 % disent avoir un niveau élevé
d'anxiété 12% niveau élevé de dépression
et ça vient avec problèmes familiaux
problèmes d'argent de sommeil
effectivement impact important sur la
santé c'est vraiment le coût réel est
complet du jeu en ligne merci beaucoup
tout en prix pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d